Look, no matter what phase of your life you're
in right now, whether you're in the new, exciting
phase, like the puppy love of a business or
relationship, or whatever you're doing, you're
so excited about it, or in the steady phase,
or momentum phase, no matter where you're
at, at some point, you're going to hit a wall.
You're just going to. And when you hit a wall,
it is very interesting when a person hits
a wall because initially when you hit a wall,
you feel like everything is going to collapse.
You feel like everything's coming down. You
feel like every single thing you are stressed
out about, you're worried about,. is going
to collapse. It's almost like you feel it's
the end of life. It's like end of the world
is coming, right? And the way you behave and
react when you hit the wall creates a habit
in your life. And one of the worst habits,
there's a lot of people that say that the
worst habit in their life is this and this
is the worst habit, I would tell you one of
the worst habits, if not the worst habit in
life is quitting. Quitting is a terrible habit
to pick up because you're going to keep quitting
in your life. You'll keep quitting in your
life and the next thing you know, every single
time you hit a wall, you'll quit.
So, I have a system that I'm going to talk
to you about today, 10 different points why
people quit and if you go through this, on
what you need to do for yourself, I'm going
through this right now, no matter what you're
going through right now in the quitting phase,
there's something to do to overcome it. No
matter what you're going through right now.
But before I even get into it, I want you
to even think about it in a complete different
way. Think about how old you are right now.
I don't know how old you are right now. I
want you to go back 10 years ago. If you're
30, you were 20. What were you worried about
that was keeping you up at night at 20 years
old? 10 years ago. What were you worried about?
What was keeping you up at night? Was it a
relationship, a girlfriend, at school a teacher,
professor, parent, argument, crisis, car payment,
tickets, suspension, DUI? What was it, 10
years ago? Do you even worry about that today?
Was it the end of the world? No? The same
thing is with business. Every single person
that builds a big business, at many different
points of their career have to slay some dragons.
You just have to slay some dragons. And the
better you go within time, the easier it gets
on slaying the next dragon.
So now let's talk about why people quit, 10
different reasons.
#1: The number one reason why people quit
where you hit a wall and say things like,
"I don't think I can do this anymore! Why
am I putting myself through this? I can't
do this anymore! Why am I putting myself through
this?" You'll be in the car - I did this many,
many different times in my life. The number
one reason why I believe people get into the
quitting phase and why people quit is they're
overwhelmed. You're simply overwhelmed. And
when we're overwhelmed, in that state, that's
when you either increase your identity as
a leader, you stay the same, or you go lower.
It's very simple. So when you're overwhelmed,
what could cause overwhelm? For instance,
think about it this way. One of them could
be you're performing, you're building a business,
and the next thing you know, one of your competitors
is beating you. You feel overwhelmed. And
then you notice somebody that opened a business,
even they have less experience than you, but
they're beating you. You still feel overwhelmed.
It could be you're not performing at a level
that you should be performing, you're overwhelmed.
It could be somebody that's a mentor of yours,
or somebody that's pushing you from the top,
you feel overwhelmed. It could be somebody
that's challenging you, you feel overwhelmed.
It could be certain financial issues you're
facing, you could feel overwhelmed. It could
be you're running the business, and you kind
of are telling yourself, "You know, honestly,
I don't think I can run a business because
I'm dealing with my marriage here and my relationship
and my kids here and my mom told me the other
day I'm not being a good son, and this person
over here and that text I got from my old
friend, and I'm no longer a loyal Lakers fan
or a Cowboy's fan. And I just feel so overwhelmed.
I don't think I can handle this! I'm overwhelmed.
So it creates pressure. You feel overwhelmed,
pressure, easiest thing to do is what? I quit.
I can't do this anymore. By the way, this
is not just in business. This happens in sports.
When you're playing sports, when you're a
kid, and you're playing for a coach that's
very much pushing everybody. If you played
for Bill Belichick, how do you think he is
in the locker room? Do you really think he's
like, "Hey, good job, guys, you did phenomenal.
Don't worry, we lost. Do you think Bill Belichick
is an easy coach to play for? You play for
me you're going to win championships, but
it's not easy playing for a coach like that.
If you're going to make a decision to play
for someone like that, they're going to push
you. So imagine you're a 16-year-old kid,
you're playing for this coach. And you're
number six, you're the sixth man on the basketball
team.
You want to get starting time, but you're
not because this other kid is taking the position
away from you, and the coach is pushing you.
You feel pressured. You come home. You don't
know what to do. You're talking to your mom.
You're talking to your dad, you don't want
to bring it up to your dad that you want to
quit basketball. Your mom says, "Maybe you
ought to quit. Don't worry about it, baby,
it's too much pressure." Maybe your mom tells
you go do it. And then that's a habit, on
what you do in that moment. That's a habit
on what you do in that moment. That's the
overwhelm part. The good news is, yes, you're
overwhelmed. If you can get through the overwhelming
phase, you're going to grow to be a whole
different person after that.
#2: Lack of results. No matter what you do,
if a person gets lack of results, and a lack
of results is purely a reflection of lack
of activity. Lack of results is not going
to happen accidentally. Let me explain to
you what I mean by this. Let's just say you
give me somebody that's never played basketball
ever in their lives. They've never played
basketball. You may be watching this saying,
"Honestly, Pat, I can't stand it when you
use basketball analogies on Valuetainment
because I don't follow basketball." No problem.
I want you, okay? You've never played basketball
before. You never shot a single shot in basketball
in your life before. I bring you in. You're
20 years old. And you and I, our goal is for
you to make 10 shots, from the free throw
line. Okay? If you have to make 10 shots from
the free throw line, what are the chances
of you making 10 shots from the free throw
line if I only give you 10 options? 10 chances.
What are the chances? Can we say zero? Because
you've never played basketball before. So
you're going to shoot an air ball, you're
going to shoot it over. And maybe you'll get
lucky and make one. You've never shot basketball
before. But here's the second equation. What
if I tell you you have an unlimited amount
of shots you take. You think you'll eventually
make 10 shots? Yes. See, lack of results,
which is the shots you make, is a reflection
of lack of activity, which if you only take
shots and you miss, of course it's not going
to work. An entrepreneur, a businessman, you
need to take so much activity to create results
because you're an amateur, you're not an expert
yet. And so the formula of capitalism, guys,
I will tell you one thing about capitalism
and sales. People hate it when I say this.
It's 100% proven where anybody can make it.
Anybody can make it. Anybody can make it in
the world of sales and capitalism because
it's purely a mathematical formula, simple
as that. It's purely a mathematical formula.
But when somebody doesn't get results, because
of their activity, then they quit. And they
think it's the industry. You know what, it
didn't work. Real estate didn't work out for
me. How come it has for hundreds of thousands
of people? You know, this didn't work out
for me. That didn't work out for me. No, you're
simply creating a habit of quitting.
Point #3. Point number three is self-sabotage.
Self-sabotage, my gosh, that's a dangerous
one because self-sabotage happens when you're
all by yourself and nobody's around you. So
you're in the car, you're going home, you're
by yourself. You're telling yourself things,
you're feeding yourself things. And then you
start believing it. And so one of the things
that you will realize is, you know, the same
people, the world has roughly 7.2 billion
people living in it today. 7.2 billion people
living in it today. Roughly 400 million are
entrepreneurs out of the 7.2 billion. Only
400 million are entrepreneurs. How many do
you think quit? But they tried entrepreneurship
at some point. Think about that. 7.2 billion,
400 million. How many quit? So why do you
think those people quit? Because at some point
they convinced themselves that they can't
do it. At some point they listened to themselves
that they can't do it. And the other guy who
makes it, he listened to himself and made
himself believe that he can't do it, when
he was alone, and nobody was around. Self-sabotage
is when you're in your car by yourself. Self-sabotage
is when you're in your office by yourself.
Self-sabotage is when it's at night and everybody's
asleep, and you're feeding yourself in bed,
saying, "My gosh, I can't do it." Self-sabotage
happens when you're all alone by yourself
and here's the good news about self-sabotage.
You ready for the good news on self-sabotage?
The same effort that it takes to sell yourself,
that you can't do something, is the same exact
effort it takes to sell yourself that you
can do it! It's just you're a great salesman.
You're just selling this product. Just start
selling this product. This product says you
can do it. This product says you can't do
it. This is an easier product to sell. It's
the same effort. So start sabotaging yourself,
and tell yourself, I can do it. And look what
happened. Mark my words, when I got started
as a brand spanking new entrepreneur, they
told me put a list of affirmations, things
you read to yourself every day. I had it everywhere.
One time a mentor of mine came to my house
and I'll never forget this. He came to my
house and he was taking a shower, because
this was a good friend of mine. And next thing
you know he's in there for an hour. I'm concerned,
why are you in there for an hour? He comes
out and he's screaming. Because he's reading
all my affirmations, and he's fired up. Lit
up. Man, I feel so good! I said, "I read that
every single day." Man, I feel so good right
now. I said, "I read it every day." I didn't
believe in myself. I was the guy that gave
up on every single thing. Let me tell you
one thing about this cat here. My dad, till
today, has a trophy on his desk, in his house.
It's the only trophy his son ever got. This
six-four, 240 body frame only got one trophy
in sports in his life. Do you know what the
trophy was? We lost to a team by 100 points.
When I was 14 years old. 100 points we lost.
And we got a trophy for losing. You would
say at least stop the game after 50 points,
these kids, put them through - 100 point trophy.
He's still got it. So I'm not coming from
a background of I was an all-star pitcher
and a baseball and basketball starting lineup.
Far from it. I never played organized sports
in my life. Never played organized sports
in my life. Ever. But self-sabotage, you've
got to learn the art of going to the next
side.
Next, #4, problem magnet. Some people are
problem magnets. I call it crap magnet. If
you want to call it. They just tend to attract
crap in their lives. And one of the reasons
why people attract crap in their lives, and
this is going to be strange when you hear
this, and it's going to be tough for some
people to hear this, one of the reasons why
some people attract crap in their lives is
because they want to. And I'll tell you why
they want to. Because if you have crap in
your life, you have an out why you didn't
make it. So you have to attract crap because
it's like, Well, I didn't make it because
my family was going through this. Well, I
didn't make it because you know, my car broke
down. Well, I didn't make it because my teacher.
. . Well, I didn't make it because I had a
kid and I was a single father. Well, I didn't
make it because my marriage didn't work. Well,
I didn't make it because I got a DUI. I didn't
make it because my car broke down.
No, you kind of want those things to happen
to you so you can advertise it and say that's
why you didn't make it. Here's the kicker.
Those same people that make it, they also
had those things happen to them as well. They
just don't advertise it. They don't advertise
it because the more you advertise it, the
more you attract crap. The less you advertise
it, the less you're attracting crap. Think
about if a girl goes out there and she's at
a bar, and she advertises and says, Oh, you
guys won't understand what just happened.
My boyfriend just cheated on me. And he broke
up with me. And I hate him so much." She's
a target. Here are a bunch of single drunk
men that are saying, "target. Let me take
advantage of this opportunity." No, it's a
target. Somebody goes out there and says,
oh, you know, I just came out of the casino
and you go to a bar, late at night, and you
go to a casino and you go to a bar and you
say, "Oh, you won't believe what just happened."
What happened? "I just went to the casino
and I won $20,000 cash, man, I've got it in
my pocket right now, $20,000 cash." What are
you potentially attracting? A bunch of people
that can jump you outside and take your $20
grand from you. You're attracting crap. Because
you're advertising to attract crap. If you
go out there and keep talking about my life
sucks, this happened to me, that happened
to me, you're telling the world, please send
more crap my way. Please send more crap my
way. And eventually, you quit. Boom.
#5: Bad decisions. Life is about decisions.
Choices. Quitting is also about bad decisions.
Bad decisions could be what? Somebody keeps
telling you you can't build a business or
you shouldn't be in a certain thing you're
doing or this is just not for you, you're
not smart enough for it. And you keep going
back and being around this person. And you
don't know it, just like you never know who
you got the flu from, or cold from, you could
have shook someone's hand that went like this,
and they had the flu and gave it to you. You
will never be able to pinpoint where you got
that flu from. It's the same exact thing when
you sit down next to somebody and they tell
you what are you doing doing business? You
can't build a business. You don't even know
it. You just got the flu. That flu is called,
"you're about to quit." That's what bad decisions
are. That's a bad decision. A bad decision
is you should have stayed at the office on
Friday night when you didn't hit your numbers
and you wanted to go to the nightclub. That's
a bad - why go to the nightclub? For what?
You don't have 100 grand in the bank yet.
You haven't made your millions yet. For what,
go to the nightclub? For what? You're going
over here and, "You know, I really don't feel
good today." You should go read or develop
or do something or study, immerse yourself
in your industry. You go and hang out and
shoot pool. For what? Bad decisions. We can't
control bad decisions. You control bad decisions.
Because you make the decisions.
#6: Procrastination. Procrastination gets
so many people where it's we'll do it later,
we'll get it done later, not right now, maybe
later, maybe this, that's a terrible, terrible,
habit. It's just as bad as quitting because
typically quitting is a by-product of somebody
that constantly procrastinates, and then all
of a sudden they start quitting everything.
So procrastination hurts a lot of people.
#7 is an interesting one that I want to dive
into and that's being a loner. Being a loner
hurts a lot of people in business. Because
look, let me just put it to you this way.
If you're married, and you're going through
issues when you're married, the worst thing
you could do is not have somebody else that
you can have a conversation with that tells
you, typically someone that's ahead of you
in marriage. So, if you've been married three
years, it may not be a bad idea to talk to
somebody that's been married for 20 years
and they've got three kids and you know, whatever.
So they're going to tell you, it's normal
what you're going through. "Here's what happened
to my wife and I. Here's what we went through
and it's fine." Oh, man, I'm not by myself.
If you're a loner, you think you're the only
one that's going through this problem. Oh
my gosh, it's only me. Because you're a loner,
you're afraid, you're a loner. No, you've
got to have some people around that are similar
level as you, if not higher to tell you, "I've
been there before. I've been there before.
Here's what you're going through." So in the
world of business, you know, you hit a certain
wall and you don't know how to get through
it and you're not talking to the right person,
and you say, man, I'm the only person that's
going through this. I must be horrible at
what I'm doing in this business. I'm an underachiever.
There's no way in the world I'm going to make
it in life.
Nope, you're simply a loner. It's not true.
You're a loner. You're being by yourself.
You're not around other people that are going
to kick your butt a little bit, or lift you
up, when you need it. Loner. It's a difficulty.
Being a loner doesn't help you. Now keep this
in mind. What do I mean by being a loner?
Sometimes a contradiction to that is, "Well,
Pat, I don't really get it, because aren't
you supposed to a loner when you become an
entrepreneur? You're all by yourself and it's,
you know, you're alone at the top and all
of this." You know, that whole thing about
you're alone at the top, it's a lie. What
you're alone at the top? Are you kidding me?
Who's alone at the top? How many million dollar
homes are there in America? Two? How many
million dollar homes are there in the world?
Three? C'mon, man. There are millions of million
dollar homes. There's a million people at
the top. That's not alone. You've just got
to find them. "It's a lonely thing at the
top." It's not. There's times when you're
in your car by yourself on the way to the
top, maybe you feel lonely at the time, sure.
Sure you do. But you can still find some people
that are at a similar position, if not higher,
that can lift you up.
#8, self-doubt. Self-doubt, man, the word,
doubt, dwell, when we sit there and dwell
on a problem, then we doubt ourselves, you
know, these d words are very, very dangerous
emotions, with dwelling and doubting and again,
with self-doubt comes lack of activity and
lack of activity produces no results, then
you question your ability and you say, I don't
know if I can really do this, and why am I
putting myself through this, and then you
quit.
So you've got to know when you're going through,
one of the things when you're having doubt,
and you're dwelling, the best thing you can
do is the following thing. When it's happening,
[snap], you've got to catch it. Oh, I'm dwelling.
I'm doubting. Whoa, stop. You're not winning.
Literally, I would speak to myself. "I'm not
buying this." My dad could tell you, he just
flew into town to spend some time with us
for Thanksgiving. My dad will tell you, we'd
be at family gatherings and somebody would
say something that's their truth, and I would
say, "You know what, I'm not buying that."
That's your mindset. But I'm not buying that.
And my dad would say, "Pat, why would you
say that?" I'm not buying that mindset. I'm
not going to allow my brain to buy that. There's
no way in the world I'm buying that. It's
for sale. The world's going to buy it because
it's for sale. Everybody wants to buy things
for sale. I want to pay full price. That's
what I want to buy. I'm not buying that. Okay,
Pat. Okay. I'm not buying that. I'm not buying
that. "All women are like this." I'm not buying
that. "All men are like this." I'm not buying
that. "All entrepreneurs are like this." I'm
not buying that. I'm not buying that.
Today in the political world, what is it?
All Republicans are like this. All Democrats
are like this. All blacks, all Hispanics,
all Muslims. I'm not buying that. All? I'm
not buying that. So you've got to be aware
when you're going into self-doubt mode, and
you say, "Nobody in my family's ever made
it," I'm not buying that. I'm going to make
it. You don't understand. I don't have a degree.
I'm not buying that. I'm going to make it.
I'm going to make it. So you've got to identify
it, stop it, say I'm not buying that. I'm
not buying something for sale. Just say it
with me. Repeat it with me, "I'm not buying
that." Say it out loud, baby. I'm not buying
that. Don't buy it. It's on sale. Pay full
price. It's the best product you'll ever buy,
when you pay full price.
Next, #9, selective hearing. It's very problematic
if you listen to the wrong thing. Let me tell
you what selective hearing is. Selective hearing
is the following. I could have a conversation
when you're down and out, and you're overwhelmed
and you want to quit. Everything you look
for, you look for signs to what? Quit. Selective
hearing. So you'll drive in a car, and a sign
will say, "Too much pressure in your life?
Maybe you ought to come and work at Kaiser
Permanente and $49,000 salary, and benefits,
and you're like, "That's a sign! Because I
was thinking about health insurance. It's
a sign God's given for me to quit!" No, no,
no. It's selective hearing is what it's called.
That's simply what it is. Because right across
the street there was a sign that said you
can have all your dreams, but you didn't look
at it. Because you saw it and said, "Nope.
That's not true. I'm looking over here." Selective
hearing. Selective hearing is you can talk
to somebody and they talked and they challenged
you, and they re-remind you of things you've
done, where you could go out there and go
win, and they tell you those two areas that
you need to improve; selective hearing says,
"Did you hear what he said on the conference
call? He told me those two things I need to
improve in. What he's trying to say is I'm
not good. This is why I can't do it." No!
He told you already. Selective hearing. You
chose to listen to this. Selective hearing.
Selective hearing. You've got to choose what
you choose to listen to. That's selective
hearing.
#10, last one. Who's in your ear? Let me tell
you why who's in your ear. We get thousands
and thousands of comments every day on Valuetainment.
And people say, "I watch this religiously."
I was at the life insurance convention, it's
called NAILBA. Every single year where all
these insurance companies get together. Any
of the biggest insurance companies in the
world, I was there for two days. These are
every year when you do your strong negotiations.
This year's was epic, because it was a completely
different story. So anyway, so I'm there,
several guys constantly, "Hey Pat," one guy
comes, who's a very, very successful, $100
million a year type of guy. He says, "I will
never miss an episode on Valuetainment. Never.
You're the first thing I start my day off
with. I watch every single episode on Valuetainment.
Every single episode on Valuetainment." That's
great. But even Valuetainment episode can
be 30 minutes long. You've got to figure out
a way to find out who's feeding you. So who's
feeding you? Who's in your ear? Who's in your
ear? Do you control who's in your ear? Who
has influence over you? Who has influence
over you? Who's telling you what to do? Who?
Is it people that are ahead? Is it people
that are feeding your fear? The most important
appointment of the day is your last appointment
of the day. You know who the last appointment
of the day is? I did an episode once, if you
haven't watched it, you've got to watch it.
It's called The Most Important Appointment
of an Entrepreneur. [Let's put a thumbnail
of it, Dennis, so they can see it. And we'll
put a link somewhere as well, Rebecca, so
they can see it as well.] It's the most important
appointment of an entrepreneur. It's called
the last appointment of the day. You know
what it is? It's the last person you talk
to when you go to sleep. You know who's the
last person you talk to before you go to sleep?
Whoever that person is. It may be your girlfriend.
Your boyfriend, mom, dad, brother, sister,
wife, husband. Whoever the last person you
talk to before you go to sleep, whatever they
feed your ear, that's how you're going to
go to sleep dreaming or having nightmares
about it. So if I go to sleep and my spouse
says, "Babe, this is scary, babe. I see you
being so stressed, I see gray hair. I'm seeing
this, this, this, this." Fear, fear, fear,
I go to sleep with fear. I wake up with fear.
This [quit] is what I want to do. But if I
go to sleep with my last appointment of the
day and the person says, "Babe, I know it's
tough, but I don't know why, babe, I just
believe in you, babe. Honey, I don't know
what it is. I just believe in you. Son, I
just believe in you. You know, brother, I
believe in you. Bro, I believe in you. Sister,
I believe in you. Girlfriend, I believe in
you. I believe in you." There's only two people
in the world you need to believe in you. One
is yourself. And one is just another person.
I don't care who it is. Just another person.
If you've got these two people, you can take
over the world, if you wanted to. So you've
got to make sure you talk to somebody that
believes in you. And you've got to make sure
you believe in yourself. Because if you don't
do those two things, you're facing this [quit]
right here. And quitting as an entrepreneur,
you don't want to do that.
So, with that being said, this is an episode
that I've been very excited about. By the
way, this here, this board I'm holding on
to was given to me as a gift Drapela Woodworks.
I met him at Texas A & M, a young kid as an
entrepreneur. He's doing a great job out there,
this past week when I was out there.
But if you've got any questions about today's
episode, comment on the bottom, on quitting.
Maybe you have some other thing that you want
to put down there as well. So share this video
with somebody. I will tell you, there's a
lot of people that are going through a lot
of difficulties right now in America, especially
with challenges we're facing in America politically,
some people are thinking about quitting their
life, let alone business, is what I'm talking
about. But there are a lot of people that
just think it's the end of life. So share
this message with a handful of people, you'd
be amazed by the response you're going to
get from some people and how grateful they'll
be.
Anyways, with that being said, look, if you
haven't subscribed to this channel, please
do so. Make sure you subscribe to this channel.
Another thing I want to tell you guys that
we just did in the last episode is we are
looking for a new pillow. We're looking for
a new pillow for Valuetainment. This pillow
is a pillow that we've for now, I want to
say about a year we've had on this channel.
We're looking for a new pillow. You can be
creative with it. It's got to have the YouTube
sign on it and Valuetainment, whatever you
want to do to be custom. Several people have
already emailed us, told us they're sending
a pillow over, and we'll choose a pillow by
the end of the year for 2017. And if your
pillow is chosen, we'll obviously show some
of them, but if your pillow is chosen, we
will definitely let everybody know that you
sent the pillow to us. The address to send
it out to is 5001 Spring Valley Road, 1155
East is the suite number, 1155 East is the
suite number, Dallas, Texas, zip code 75244,
send your pillow over. Again, if you haven't
subscribed to the channel, please do so. If
you've got any questions or thoughts, comment
on the bottom. Take care everybody. Bye, bye.